right now the prevailing theory of how
the universe came about is commonly
called the Big Bang Theory Big Bang
Theory and really is just this idea that
the universe started is kind of this
infinitely small point this infinitely
small singularity and then it just had a
Big Bang or just expanded from that
state to the universe that we know right
now and when I first imagined this and I
think it's it's also a byproduct of how
it's named Big Bang you kind of imagine
this this type of explosion you kind of
imagine this type of explosion that
everything was infinitely packed in
together and then it exploded and then
it exploded outward and then as all of
the matter export' exploded outward it
started to condense and then you have
these little galaxies and superclusters
of galaxies and they started to condense
and then within them a planets condensed
and stars condensed and we have the type
of universe that we have right now but
this model for visualizing the Big Bang
has a couple of problems one is when we
talk about the Big Bang we're not
talking about the matter just the the
mass or just the matter in the universe
being in one point we're talking about
actual space expanding so we're not just
talking about something inside of space
like the physical mass the physical
matter expanding we're talking about
space itself and so when you have this
type of model you have all of this stuff
expanding but you're like well look
isn't it expanding into something else
isn't you know maybe if if the the
furthest out parts of this matter is
right over here is right over here
what's this stuff over here and until
you say well you know wouldn't that be
space so how can you say space itself is
expanding and another idea that a Big
Bang also implies is if this is the
furthest stuff out there would this be
would this be the edge of the universe
does the universe have an edge and the
answer to either those questions that's
right what we're going to try to tackle
in this is that one the universe does
not have an edge and two there is no
outside space we are not expanding into
another space and I'm going to explain
that hopefully we'll see why
that is the case right now so the best
way to view it and we're going to view
it by analogy we're going to view it by
analogy if I were to tell you that I
have a a 2-dimensional a two-dimensional
space a two-dimensional space
two-dimensional space that has a finite
area so it has a finite area finite area
so it's not infinite and it also has no
edge it also has no edge this once again
at first when you first look at it it
seems difficult how do i construct
something that has a finite area but
still has no edge every time I try to
draw an area it looks like I have to
have some edges and then you might
remember what if that two-dimensional
space is curved what happens and I think
the easiest example of that is the
surface of a sphere the surface of a
sphere let me draw a sphere over here so
this right here is a sphere let me draw
some some equal longitude and latitude
and the lines on this sphere on this
sphere all of a sudden and I'll shade it
in a little bit make it look nice this
type of a sphere you have a finite a
finite area you can imagine the surface
of a balloon or the surface of a bubble
or the surface of the earth you have a
finite area but you have no edge if you
keep going forever in one direction if
you keep going forever in one direction
you're just going to keep and go all the
way around and come back and come back
to the other side now to imagine a
three-dimensional space that has the
same properties a finite area and and I
want to I don't want to say find out
area anymore because we're not talking
about a three-dimensional space let me
draw it over here so let's think about a
three dimensional space so three three
dimensional three dimensional space
instead of area since we're in three
three dimensions now I want to talk
about a finite volume finite finite
volume and no edge how do I do that and
when you think about it superficially
well well look if I have a finite volume
it's going to be in you know maybe
you can contained in some type of a cube
and then we clearly have edges in those
situations or you could even think about
a finite volume as being the inside of a
sphere and that clearly has an edge this
entire surface over there so how do you
construct a three-dimensional space that
has finite volume and no edge and that
I'm going to tell you right now it's
very hard for us to visualize it but in
order to visualize it I'm going to draw
the same thing as I drew right here but
we would you're what you have to imagine
and you almost have to imagine it by
analogy unless you have some type of a
profound brain wired for more than three
- more than three spatial dimensions is
a sphere but so let me make it clear
this is a this is a two-dimensional
surface two dimensional surface right on
the surface of the sphere you can only
move in two directions - two
perpendicular directions you could move
like that or you could move like that
you can move left and right or you can
move up and down so it's a
two-dimensional surface of of a three
dimensional a three-dimensional sphere
so if we take it by analogy let's
imagine and it's hard to imagine a
three-dimensional surface a
three-dimensional surface and you can do
it mathematically the math here is
actually not that difficult it's a three
dimensional surface of a four
dimensional sphere of a four dimensional
four-dimensional sphere and I'm going to
draw it the same way so if we kind of
view those three dimensions or just
these two dimensions of the surface the
same thing it's the same thing and if
you imagine that I'm not saying that
this is actually the shape of the
universe we don't know the actual shape
but we do know that it does have a
slight curvature but we don't know the
actual shape but a sphere is the
simplest there's other ones we could do
a toroid would also fit the bill of
having a finite volume with no edge and
another thing I want to make it clear we
actually don't even know whether it has
just a finite volume that's still an
open question but what I want to do is
show you that it can have a finite
volume and also have no edge and most
the
most people believe and I want to say
believe here because you know we can
just go based on evidence and all that
that we are talking about something with
a finite volume especially when you talk
about the Big Bang Theory that kind of
on some on some dimension implies a
finite volume although it could be a
super large unfathomably large volume it
is finite now if if you have this let's
imagine this sphere let's imagine this
sphere once again if you're on this
surface of this four dimensional sphere
I have as you can't not I cannot draw
four dimensional sphere but if you're on
the surface of this four dimensional
sphere if you go in any direction you
will come back out and come back to
where you started if you go that way
you'll come back around here now the
universe is super huge so even light
maybe light itself would take an
unbelievable amount of time to traverse
it and if this sphere if the sphere
itself is expanding it might be
expanding so fast that light might not
ever be able to come back around it but
in theory if something were fast enough
if something were to keep going around
it could eventually go back to this
point now when we talk about a
three-dimensional surface it's a
three-dimensional surface of a four
dimensional sphere that means that any
of the three dimensions over here on the
surface I can only draw two but that
means if this is true if we if the
universe is a three-dimensional surface
of a four dimensional sphere that means
that if you go if you go up and you just
keep going up you'll eventually come
back from the bottom so if you keep
going if you keep going all the way up
you'll eventually come back to the point
that you are it might be an unbelievably
large distance but you'll eventually get
back where you were if you go to the
right you'll eventually come back all
the way around to the point where you
are and if you were to go into the page
so if you were to go into the page let
me draw it that way if you were to go
into the page you would eventually come
back from above the page and come back
to the point that you are so that's what
this implication would be that you would
eventually get back to where you are so
let's go back to the question of an
expanding universe a you know expanding
universe that's not expanding into any
other space that is all of the space but
it's still expanding
well this is the model so you could
imagine shortly after the Big Bang our
four dimensional sphere look like this
maybe it was a little small four
dimensional sphere at some you know
maybe you know right at the Big Bang it
was like this little unbelievably small
sphere then a little bit later it's this
larger sphere let me just shade it in to
show you that it has three that it has
that it's kind of popping out of the
page that it's a sphere and then in the
later time the sphere might look like
this the sphere might look like this now
your your temptation might be to say
what wait Sal isn't this stuff outside
of the sphere isn't that some type of a
space that's expanding into isn't that
somehow part of the universe and I would
say if you're if you're talking in three
dimensions no it's not the entire
universe is this surface it is this
surface of this four dimensional sphere
if you start talking about more
dimensions then yes you could talk about
maybe things outside of our
three-dimensional universe
so as this expands in space-time so you
can all you know one way to view the
fourth dimension is it is time itself
things are just getting further and
further apart and I'll talk about more
evidence in future videos for why we why
the Big Bang is the best theory we have
out there right now but as you can
imagine if - if we have two points on
this sphere that are that far apart as
this sphere expands this
four-dimensional sphere as this bubble
blows up or this balloon blows up those
two points are just let me draw three
points let's say those are three points
those three points are just going to get
further and further apart and that's
actually one of the main points that
that or one of the one of the first
reasons why it made sense to leave the
Big Bang is that everything is expanding
not from some central point but
everything is expanding from everything
that if you put any direction from any
point in the universe everything else is
expanding away and the further away you
go it looks like the [ __ ] the faster its
expanding away from you so I'll leave
you there something for you to kind of
think about a little bit and then and
then we'll build on some of this to
think about what it means to kind of
observe the observable
universe